Joe's like I have my moments and Bart's
like I needed to last
right yeah yeah Joe's like I could bust
it over the road yeah but it's like I
need to bust forever
[Music]
welcome back to a very special careful
boys where we are indeed very careful
boys and today we're talking about what
does making it look like to you oh man
making it it's a question we all have
when you make it what's it gonna look
like I feel like I made it oh [__] off
[Laughter]
that's good I feel like I [__] made
it but once you make it you have a whole
new set of Dreams because your reality
changes okay interesting like so like
when you I think when I was younger and
then I was dreaming about a lot of
things like oh I can't wait till
um I achieve these goals or whatever
right for some reason we all have this
thought well at least I did where once
you get there everything is coasting
from there that's what I believed but
then there's also a point where you
achieve everything and then
you don't have anything else after that
that's also sad too because then like
you're like okay I got what I wanted I
have this money goal everything goal I
checked off all the things right
but then if you don't really have
anything else or purpose or
something to fight for I guess like
there's it's like life is not
meaningless but it gets really boring
quick like you can only do so much of
just having as much fun as you want
eating as much as you want there's
there's a point where if you just live
for Pleasures then
there's this weird thing that happens
where it's like the opposite of it
becomes too normal to the point where
you need something right it's like the
living the hedonistic lifestyle I didn't
go that far but really it's like how
close would you come not as hardcore as
like rock star status where you're coked
out and having orgies and [__] but my
wholesome level of like like I agree
unlimited amounts of snowboarding
[__] playing and just traveling
without anyone to be responsible for you
don't get eaten every Tuesday every
[__] sexual escort pain I wanted
Tuesday and Thursday yeah Thursday let's
go and that's Taco Tuesday that's a lot
for a woman to commit to on a Taco
Tuesday well if you do it in the morning
then it's before you eat chocolate oh
that's good so it would be Wednesday
that's the really bad yeah Wednesdays
yeah don't do it it's like don't do it
Wednesday yeah that's Taco Wednesday
because Taco Tuesday so the follow-up
yeah the diarrhea Wednesdays yep but
then maybe Thursday alliteration I'm
looking for
like the what the [__] Wednesday or
something yeah Wednesday Wednesday or we
should do this later Wednesday yeah
still good but I I what I realize is I
like that feeling of when I make it yeah
I don't actually like to be in the state
of made it if that I don't know like I
know what you mean yeah it's like I'm
looking for the next thing I like to run
my marathon without even getting to the
Finish Line I just like to keep running
yeah I think um for the sake of the
conversation I think I might have a more
objective concept but again same maybe
never have you made it and then also in
context I do agree with the idea that
like if I were like if my younger self
were to see what I'm doing right now and
or how much I'm making for doing what I
love that younger self would be like you
[__] made it exactly that definitely
I agree with that 100 and and I have to
remind myself of that sometimes in order
to be grateful for like whatever
lifestyle that I have today right
um but I think in in a more objective
concept I think if I
I think I would assume or or uh uh
accept that I quote unquote made it if I
didn't have to work I don't think that I
would necessarily live a purposeless
life and not do something that committed
to purpose whether it be as Noble as
like charitable stuff all day or or just
a hedonistic lifestyle of like playing
around and just like doing things that
are of pleasurable fun without
responsibility and care I I regardless
of what I was doing I think the concept
of never having to work anymore because
things were just uh done and I do think
a lot of it unfortunately does come down
to things like money and resources and
finances like if I just didn't have to
work I could still choose to yeah and I
could still choose to fulfill my time
with things that are either of like you
know passion desire purpose and or just
regular work but if I didn't have to
because I was taken care of and enough
of a lifestyle that would be like
multi-generational
um I could take care of my parents and I
could take care of like future children
and myself in the current lifestyle I
think that financially I would assume
that I'd be like that's considered
making it so your your goal is to be a
trust fund baby Ashton kutchman would
hate you because he doesn't want to
leave anything first I feel like you
guys have blown that out of proportion
but yes I agree that's that's my
definition of making it where you don't
have to work
for like covering your bills because I
think that's what
pollutes the purity of your work so
recently um maybe like two or three
weeks ago I went to go eat barbecue with
David uh Adam Perry Lane's place so he's
like arguably like one of the best pit
Masters ever
and I started talking and when you see
him working like he's doing these pop-up
shops he has this giant [__] trailer
and he's an artist right like he's a
Michelin star Chef a French train but
also really good with barbecue and I
asked them I'm like how come you don't
open up a restaurant and he goes I had
restaurants I had a bunch of them but he
goes the minute you have a restaurant
you have to commercialize and monetize
it so if your heart is here but if
burgers and fries or steaks whatever
makes money you have to do this to keep
the place open he goes right now I can
do whatever crazy ass shrimps that I
want I could do smoke duck the next day
I can constantly focus on my art and I'm
like damn that's really cool because I
don't think I'm gonna be an unproductive
person but it's every time I think when
you're in any type of creative Endeavor
you're always faced with this fork in
the road you're like dude I really want
to do this artistically but then you're
like but
does this make the most sense for the
whole team financially and then when you
have to make those decisions it almost
feels like you either you're either
stabbing yourself or you're stabbing the
artwork or you're stabbing whatever so
if I can get to a point where like
um passively somehow all of my [__] is
taken care of now every single thing I
can do it for why I want to do it
whether it is a charity or or whatever
then I can just solely focus on that and
I feel like I'd be like that to me would
be making it because now I get to kind
of like have my cake and eat it too what
is something you would do for example so
come on nandy the [__] you just said so
one thing one of the things was uh
whether crypto made it big or something
or any other thing that like really like
if anything blew up for me like if you
had like 20 million dollars yeah and
then now you just don't have to work so
one one thing that I wanted to do was
like let's say I had some like let's say
I came across like a million dollars
somehow I wanted to take at least a
hundred aside and just make 10 whatever
short films and submit all of them but
then like spend like 10 G's on each one
and but now each one is a hundred
percent purely for me did you just make
a million dollars off your forever home
I didn't see 10 films come out yeah but
that's not enough though you know I mean
I need like enough to where like if if
it really not to blow it you don't want
to blow a million dollars yeah if I
covered my [__] be 20x to a million
dollars see that's different yeah yeah
then I can like fully do what I want and
then really figure out if things made it
because I'm lacking the skill or lacking
the whatever or versus me making
decision out of external factors yeah
but like yeah movies is top is up there
for me
um
also just shooting dumb things like
[__] real life Tonka trucks smashing
mountains and like you know like like uh
tar and Feathering like Boeing 747 like
that kind of [__] is still up there oh
that's right yeah yeah yeah such a
passion project making them look like
eagles hey making them look like eagles
yeah yeah
but movies is a is a big one though it's
a big one still made it you made it Joe
you can jerk it as much as you want all
day nobody's gonna bug you sometimes I
wake up in the morning and I fondle
myself and I look over at Hannah and I'm
on like
I made it bro cause now I could jack off
or have sex with her yeah and I can do
whatever and then I still get to come I
get to I so many ways I can go to the
bathroom right now jack off in the
shower I could do a lot of things I made
it bro it's the simple things in life
it's the simple simple things guess what
you think Tutankhamun could do that [__]
nope he's dead as a mummy he had to jerk
off with [__] Stones
yeah it's going like that trying to make
fire on his stick this is trying to get
his dick off you know what I'm trying to
do I'm trying to be a kid again because
you know kids don't have financial
responsibility yes so like that where
you can your financial [__] your real
[__] your world your real world [__] is
covered so you can go back into a space
where you could just be like a kid this
child like Wonder and follow me what's
stopping you from doing having moments
of that like failing JK
true because I don't know like for maybe
going down the toilet bowl like this
like 15 minute scooter ride for me makes
me feel like a million dollars or like
being able to just swim are they because
it's too temporary it so to me it feels
fake hmm
fleeting I don't know about fake but
fleeting yeah I guess I don't know to me
it feels like did you have the hot dog
if you just took one bite at Costco this
is why you guys are eating me that's why
you guys are eating
leading then but it works
I needed to [__] last
right yeah yeah Joe's like I could bust
it up right out yeah Bart's like I need
to bust forever I need to know that when
I bust the nuts I don't have to worry
after and Joe's like I'll figure the
next nut out I don't know
yeah maybe yeah the next nut will come
we'll just come why don't we ask a 20
millionaire yeah you wanna know what you
want to know what it feels like at the
20 million Mark yeah yeah tell us how
it's like to make it I think um I think
making it to me really is just like if
you feel like
you're happy with how you lived I think
that's pretty much making it like
looking back because not everybody's
gonna end up rich but they are going to
be satisfied with what they did oh like
they'll have a big you you look at uh
abuelito with her big family she didn't
make millions of dollars but she's
[__] happy you know like she made it
millions of babies like she made it I
think I think of it that way I think
like if you get to see the other side of
the wall in your lifetime of something
that you wondered for so long like what
was there then that's good enough to me
that's true because do you want to be
the lonely billionaire that owns the
company yes yes yes or the happy janitor
that goes home no no no [__] family
not at all well because we we've seen
like
that's another thing is that we've seen
good shoot again
people of all net worths have shot
themselves it's kind of like nobody
really you know it's not a give me a
chance and a gun let me prove them wrong
yeah so we'll show them wrong
show them all them biggest like
indicators of making it is if you wet
most of your life thinking you couldn't
do something and everyone else also
believed you couldn't do it and you
ended up doing it that's making it to me
yeah I think that's cool like like you
never work at McDonald's just watch me
[__] watch me handle this McMuffin
[__] and which is why Ryan for
JK president 2024 yeah Hall of Fame dude
kind of you know so with that definition
do you feel like you made it I think the
child version of me thinks I made it 50
times over yep agreed though absolutely
because because the things the things
that I was able to accomplish in my
lifetime weren't even on the table when
I was a kid they were all they all
sounded like made up fantasy so many
first place championships I know man
it's but but also I don't want like I
see it exactly like that way too where
it's like but the younger me is like
what the [__] how are you here and then
I can tap into that but it's not to say
I'm done
so like I don't feel like I made it I'm
done it's more like I think you're done
huh
[Laughter]
making it is like going back to what I
was saying is like once you've made it
there's a whole new set of things you're
gonna see your world opens up now it's
like what's the next I totally agree
with that I also think that us as people
uh probably also why we're friends and
why we like work together and stuff like
that like whatever our concept Even in
our minds right now we could objectively
be like oh yeah I understand that maybe
this threshold is where we made it we
probably start like 5x away from that
you know what I mean like we we might
say this man and we'd still be thirsty
for like another 5x that version
shut the [__] up
family I'm so [__] tired
my brother's like this hey my brother's
like this dude I'm not not to brag I
took this kid he put in twenty thousand
dollars in the crypto he made 900 and
[__]
sixty thousand dollars
riding with your boy yeah and it wasn't
enough and he was smart so he cashed out
no well he catch up some with me when we
when we cashed out when I sent you a
text and I said I'm cashing out when I
sent you a text that I'm cashing out he
cashed out some but again we we all wish
we left we took more out but like this
kid just couldn't [__] be happy with
turning like 20 grand into 900 that's
that's the best multiples I've ever
heard that's what I'm saying it's insane
I think uh you know I have a pretty good
method but you never know how people are
gonna respond to that right it's like oh
I need a little bit more right did I
need a little more yeah I did right
because it's like the thing where you're
like oh I'm I've been so right so far I
know I'm gonna be right again and again
and it's like dude just take some credit
for this [__] I think it's all it's
it's all about where you set the bar
right so like let's say if his bar was
500 million then he'll feel like a
failure at 10. exactly and that's what
happened ultimately and you know I love
the kid doesn't matter it doesn't matter
and you
and he care like that much like because
he was with me the first eat run when we
were like riding ethereum and he had
only put in like a small amount I think
he made like 60 000 at that time and
then he he wrote it back down but then
he wrote it back up because he was like
DC in the lows which is what you're
supposed to do but that's the whole
thing is like he knows now the method to
getting there but it's work and now he's
got to do the work again and that's kind
of like you know it almost doesn't end
like the next thing doesn't end because
you're always chasing the next piece of
work which is why you know to run his
point though like if it's not a
financial concept then it's it's not
necessary you know what I mean finances
are
think about like inflation you know what
I mean a number has this value at this
moment and then like another year it
just changes in value so soaking your
dream or soaking your concept of making
it well I think for people who have kids
it's just a different thing mine's a
very Financial number yeah monetarily
that's what my brothers like the minute
I can hit 20K a month passively
I'm done today but like if the US dollar
tanks and then 20K is like 50 bucks
because I also have uh retirement so if
I if it carries me enough and we can do
enough calculations like this even with
inflation can carry me to when I can
crack open my retirement I'm done I
don't need to like work anymore in that
sense here yeah I I again from a because
I'm not there objectively I'm I'm the
same boat I agree as long as like those
things can be taken care of from a
multi-general basis and like DCA when
you have to versus because it's fun it's
different too yes so true yeah and and
having a kid it really honestly opened
my mind a lot because like you you think
more primally yeah you're like I gotta
take care of my [__] fan and that's
why it's 20K instead of 10K because 10K
would be I mean obvious you could live a
great life on 10K passive but then
you're literally at your limits and if a
big investment comes along you don't
have anything so that's why for me it's
at 20K so that I'll probably live way
under 10k but then that gives me to a
chance to DCA every single day every
single month across all Industries you
know and then if I want to take like
random first class flights once a
quarter I still can please don't
diversify them myself
but aside from like making it monetarily
or lifestyle wise like I think there's
also just lifestyle goals accomplishing
right like yeah like there's there's a
bar we all set for like our health or
like just creatively or the things that
you want to just Express or write or
think or do
I think younger Joe was much more
concerned about those goals than
financially until I got older than it's
like
oh
family future security all those things
like they weigh out that's where
financial goals start coming in did you
realize how how much a lot of it's tied
to that you're like [__] I have a hard
time going to the gym I a higher Trader
ah [__] that costs money yeah no but
then you have a trainer you can get it
you get to your goals so much faster
because you got someone helping you
doing it with you Nick what's making it
for you man well going back to what you
guys were saying this many clients
part of me feels like in a lot of ways I
have made it right but also on the flip
side it's like the goal posts always
move you know so uh I think a big thing
is that Financial Security that like you
guys are talking about that Nest Egg
yeah that you need to have always
whether it's for you your family or just
to be able to have like a little bit
more Financial Freedom so it's like
I can't take time off if I need to or
you know be able to pay for certain
things for like my family or whatever
the case may be and also for Investments
so I think in my head there's there's
definitely a number two but it's
man a lot of ways I just want to keep
just getting better at stuff you know
just like keep getting more skills like
learning how to be better at running a
business get better at just all of the
aspects of like my life that I want to
build out you know but a lot of it too
is has to do with my wife and my family
and like it's kind of weird it's like so
corny and lame but like it's super gay
but it I'm starting to my life and my
family no but like when I come home like
that's that's like the best part of my
day you know it's like when I get to
come home after a long day of work and
just like you know doing all things I
need to do and just like kind of
chilling relaxing with my fam like
that's awesome there's nothing that
beats that so anything that could
insulate that and protect that and
expand that is definitely what is like
making it to me but it's also one of
those things where it's going to con
it's gonna require
continual skill acquisition leveling up
always and just trying to like
just move the goal post so you don't get
stagnant that's what I'm really afraid
of too is like just being stagnant being
comfortable with what I have because I
feel like
being comfortable in general is so
dangerous and so like something I am
accustomed to probably so anything that
pushes me outside of that like comfort
zone enough
safely enough where I could expand and
get better is what I would probably
consider making it yeah thank you that's
awesome no Don't Clap dude no that's
awesome I'm not done dude I do think
when when you make it too hard too quick
and it's too safe it can [__] with your
um desire to need to like fight for
stuff or survive yeah I think it's just
your goals right so me and David have
talked about this too because like it's
such a stupid thing but like he can
relate to me because like I [__] set
a goals like I want to start a [__]
movie by the time whatever and then me
and David both did that and then I was
like now what and like you the now what
is crazy on you it really is because you
didn't set another goal you're like it's
probably gonna take forever because you
you don't think it's too highly of
yourself so you're like and me and David
really have lived on that too so it's
like you don't think too high of
yourself you're like well if I get to
that I'll be crazy and then we do it way
early and then it's like what now it's
like oh [__] and that became like a
whole nother explorative thing
but like I think that for me it was like
you know like family like you're talking
about like like the other night like
like I hadn't seen I hadn't gotten to
hang with Nikki for like a couple of
days because she was like doing poker
stuff and I was doing Griffith stuff and
then like um she went to this like
sounds weird but she went to this like
[__] Chanel thing so she's uh she's
like this Gucci sponsored thing with
Chanel or whatever I don't know how's
that weird well no it's weird because
she's like sounds cool she has to go
there in the morning
and then like I'm flying out for JK so
I'm like oh [__] I won't see you for
like a couple days or whatever so then
she she texts me from there she's like
hey I'm coming home I was like oh [__]
I'm gonna see her right and that was
just so exciting for me because I'm like
that's my family right Nikki's my family
yeah and then when she got home
you know when I was putting both of my
feet on the back of her neck
and I was mounting her
that was when I was like this is what
making it is you know like I am home and
I have truly made it
you know and I had my shoes on hey you
know what's what's kind of scary though
is that we can say that we have known a
lot of people
that we have seen really make it and
then they just mentally fell apart isn't
that crazy that's what's crazy too yeah
we know people who are on top of the
world right now have the highest
attention all that stuff and they're
having a mental breakdown you know what
then we [__] made it or honestly yeah
to just to just be mentally healthy dude
that's a that's an underrated thing
that's what I'm saying because we I feel
like I'm super underrated I'm living
great I feel very grateful second place
is not that bad
your first place to me Anthony dude
first runner up somewhere
because sometimes yeah some people they
have like what's outside made it and
then you're like oh that's [__] sick
but then you yeah then you see what
happens on their insides and you're like
man maybe I don't want to make it I just
I really we've seen people fall apart
for no reason you're like did you have
everything you're at the height of your
career exactly everything's going great
and then they just freeze up and they're
like I want to kill myself yep and
you're like what I've heard people do
stuff like that that's why I like the
the struggle part of it where you're
like aiming for something and I like the
the the run because then you don't have
time to think about your trauma that's
what you're reminisce about that's why
what JK so sick I know this era is so
sick after juggle is so real there's for
real when what you have to do kind of
coincidentally aligns with what you like
to do that's a pretty [__] good
making it right when you're you just
have to pick out a pair of shoes you're
gonna step on your wife's head with yeah
and you have options you're like I
really didn't make it I can't believe I
have options yeah like I didn't used to
it could have been a sandals do this
with my bare feet now it's either Gucci
or Chanel yeah which one dude it's
always the New Balances
foreign
beautiful